inspired and here we go and Ivanka
you'll be happy with this one oh I am
delighted it's my favorite opening I
recognize it but I know that's your
favorite of me
he's not mal slipped he maybe wanted the
Sicilian but no it's a Karo Khan and the
caracon keeps tension right Ivanka
there's not many ways to force a draw
for white and that's uh that's the key
that's the first step for Anish just
survive the opening and not allow Prague
to force a draw
to make things simple to trade Queens
and already look at this Prague thinking
for 30 seconds on move two that's very
rare yeah and it's the Mind Games have
started definitely trying to pick maybe
a safer variation if I if I were Rag and
I was looking for a clear-cut way to
kind of maintain just a simple chest I
would uh be tempted actually to play
something called The Exchange variation
when the the boom appears on D5 just
take it off and we might see on the
board just yet he's developed the night
and now I'm expecting Anish to pick up
that d-pawn and challenge the E4 pawn
and uh what we see two nights instead
yeah the two nights variation named very
sophisticatedly yeah because white
snakes come out
um yeah I wonder who came up with that
one they're like oh I can't think of a
name for this oh there are two nights
out in the opening let's call it the two
nights but yeah black here I think this
is the first critical moment for initial
he brings his Bishop out this is what
you recommended in your book your
Vancouver it is and after Bishop takes
my night and now the trendy move is just
simply to push the E Pawn one square
forward and Liberate the dark Square
Bishop
it's parted with the bishop pair now
white has the two Bishops after that
Bishop Knight trade but look at that
Center for Black Rock Solid the triangle
formation we sometimes call it
um yeah black has no weaknesses at all
in this structure often you set up all
your pawns on light squares and there's
a couple of ways to play this the
ambitious way is to try and feed and get
a Black's dark Square Bishop but that's
very risky as well as far as I know so
how can Anish spice this one up create
some winning chances at least a lot of
pieces will remain on the board for a
while
I don't think he should go for any of
those variations there are a few where
black tries to equalize by force because
that will lead to potential uh
simplifications
so yeah Prague
choosing a decent variation here not
trying to refute the karakan not trying
to win after the opening which many
people try to do nowadays it's
frustrating every time I play the
caricon they're going straight for me
really aggressively but uh yeah he's
just taking a quiet this is what we
predicted
and I agree with you I don't think he
should fianchetto his bishop and instead
he plays another ambitious approach
developing the dark Square Bishop
preventing White's deep wound from
moving two squares forward
will Castle his King
to safety and one of the Black Knights
is now likely to develop
I'm not sure which one will come out
normally the white the black king side
Knight clears the path to Castle but I'm
not sure if it's in this exact position
like you're the expert here Ivanka I
should defer to you yeah and this is
this is one of those so I'm trying to
recall my theory and I'm thinking that
the Knight just comes out to as you say
probably to the E7 squirrel to the F's I
can't remember David me neither and this
is this is one of the big problems with
being a chess author is that everyone
expects you to remember your own lines
and you're like I did study here trust
me I did I just can't tell you the
subtleties right now but I think it's
just to develop the night all the
viewers at home have to go out and buy
ivanka's book to remember the subtleties
she's keeping them yeah I actually
didn't recommend this line I actually
recommend developing the night out much
earlier okay yeah
um and I guess that's another beautiful
thing about the karakan is you're so
flexible right often when I play the
caricon I'm just freestyling I'm just
trying to as long as I have a solid pool
structure like Anish does here for black
in the center then not that much can go
wrong so as long as you play quite
logically you will survive and get a
playable
little game so he does bring his Knight
out getting ready to Castle the black
king prague's gone back to his shaking
and uh yeah there's a few ways to
develop here for white normally you want
to push whites deep on two squares
forward so you can support that by
bringing bringing your Rook across you
can just push white steep on one square
you need to get organized white still
has a few pieces that are asleep
and uh yeah if you don't do anything
then Black's pieces will harmonize very
easily it's very simple to play Black in
these types of positions the less white
is very direct actually yeah and uh
obviously because the Knight has moved
to the square in front of the king
they also have to think about ideas that
black could have with it advancing with
his Pawns in the right side
yeah so you think maybe he's going to
try and attack the white king anishagiri
yeah he might do at the right time yeah
normally in the karakan normally what
you do is you never attack from the
onset you develop your pieces first you
Castle your king and only then do you
think about pushing porn pawnbrokes
because the great thing with the caracon
is that when you do actually get your
Pawn push it's actually really really
good for you and this is why often why
it's like no no you're not moving my
friend
and there you see it uh Prague is
putting pressure on the dark Square
Bishop it moves
yeah it moves but now it has lost
control over that D4 square that we've
talked about so whites are the central
form the Deep one there we go steps
forward two squares prac is occupied the
center combined with the fact he has the
bishop pair and he's got a slightly done
development having castled
looking pretty good for Prague I've got
to say maybe Anish giri is fine but in
terms of winning it's going to be
extremely difficult and uh he captures
in the Santa oh this one is going to be
a very tough nut to crack because uh
yeah Black's position is very solid but
as David says it's going to be very
difficult to generate winning Chances
with those Knights
yeah and uh blacks pieces Black's nights
aren't so active right now he activates
his Queen White tonight on the edge of
the board was going to recentralize
itself anyway it wasn't well placed
there I'm assuming Prague is going to
bring it back where it came from it
looks like White's wasted a lot of time
with his Knight there but Black's wasted
time with his bishop and it has also
forced black to clarify the center so
white tonight has achieved what it
wanted in the first place
and uh okay he doesn't he steps a pawn
forward also quite logical
and uh yeah maybe Black's Queen sortie
hasn't really achieved too much
I'm just fearful for Anish Gary actually
if white continues between Pawns in the
center but see Paul can step forward now
yeah black is the one playing for
equality is uh far from playing for the
win here yeah I agree with you here um I
think black is okay yeah he's slightly
worse
but uh this is uh bearing in mind that
Anisha is in a must-win situation this
is not the position you want this is the
kind of position you perhaps want if
you're in a draw situation yeah
and it's not an issue style normally
when he has black Anish as we've seen in
his chessable courses on you know the
French the Sicilian Night author
Sicilian dragon all his chessable causes
he wants to defend actively he wants to
be very Dynamic he wants to have winning
chances in his pocket if the opponent
goes astray here even if white messes up
slightly it's hard to imagine what can
go wrong maybe you trade a set of Pawns
in the center and black hats black has
active minor pieces finally blacks
Knights get into the game but
will Prague allow that not really
um so we do see uh there
Anish giri his French defense chess
support course a great one I must admit
I've gone through that myself but uh
this is not his ideal setup I think
maybe you're choosing the French defense
or choosing the Sicilian dragon or
something along those lines would have
been a better bet against Prague um the
Karu I love the opening
um we both do here in the studio but
yeah it looks like Prague has found a
nice way to keep things calm keep things
solid for white black does eventually
castle and now white will continue
developing his pieces
yeah and I'm just giggling away because
uh I do have to share with you David one
of the answers to our caption this
competition you'll really appreciate
this joke and it's from
sutusa I'm sorry for mispronouncing your
name but uh says uh when the game you
are commenting on last more than 300
moves that's my favorite one of the day
this is clearly a loyal viewer of the
tour I love this chess humor I mean that
was actually Simon's face when
I remember the world championship it
lasted like 136 moves game six yeah and
you were just buzzing and we were like
oh my goodness me he's going on we yeah
we were live on the show for nearly nine
hours no breaks and I was feeling pumped
I was feeling energized but Simon yeah I
think he needed he wanted to lie down
after that Marathon
um yeah great great caption there yeah
do you love those long games yeah
keep those answers coming and remember
if you do have any questions thoughts
remember you can tweet us using the
hashtag chess Champs and we will try and
feature them on the show
yep and meanwhile the first serious
think of the game from pragnananda both
sides have played very quickly up to
this point and I think that's great news
for Gary especially who struggled under
time pressure but uh yeah it's prag to
decide what to do first he wants to
develop White's dark Square Bishop but
maybe no good squares or no effective
squares for it yet so he brings this
Rook across and that white dark Square
Bishop is going to go to D2 to kick away
that black queen in the corner so very
logical stuff
expecting black to do the same at some
point to centralize the Rooks maybe
mobilize the Black Knights as well a lot
of choice for Gary maybe I've been too
harsh on the opening choice he's still
he's still all right for now he's still
all right I mean in the with this Pawn
structure the ideal scenario for black
is if they were to trade off the dark
squared Bishops you're okay with the
power of knights that's not a problem
and uh the whole idea would be just to
put use the half open d-line to put
pressure or not White's D4 Pawn so I
don't know how to get rid of the dark
Square Bishops let's uh let's as an
example let's move the Rook across and
if the bishop yeah attacks the uh black
queen then let's block and trade off
those Bishops I mean this is white
helping black slightly giving getting
rid of the Bishops totally but this is
the end goal and this ball becomes a bit
weaker yeah and then and then once just
to kind of Go Fast Forward a few moves I
mean black holes just to try and attack
the queen yeah Queen will take a step
back and then you just buy it your time
because the great thing about Black's
Pawn structure the E6 and C6 pawns is
that they're very flexible either of
them can move and uh once the black
Rooks have doubled well white will have
to calculate those two Pawn advances at
every time yeah actually this Pawn is
almost uh impossible to defend
sufficiently for white the problem is
here you have a light squared Bishop
meaning you can't defend your opponent
on a dark square and not only that
blacks Knights are very flexible and
they can start improving attacking these
pawns yeah I think that's the key
breaking up the bishop pair and if Anish
giri can do that if you can trade off
these two pieces then he will some find
a have winning chances but uh it is hard
to manufacture
so um yeah right now I'm expecting this
Rook move maybe or one of the Rook moves
uh also he could consider starting by
attacking the White Queen but no he goes
on the front foot first of all playing
very dynamically
and uh he's attacking this misplaced
Knight he's not giving way the
opportunity to bring it back into the
center and he is hoping that for example
again if the queen is attacked he can
slide in and block exchanging uh making
this dream trade and getting rid of
White's Bishop hair so I think here
Prague should just be very calm and step
back I agree actually this is also a
very thematic a poem Pawn break I mean
normally you don't tend to do it in this
particular type of position but it's
something to have in your Arsenal
because the whole point is that after
Pawn takes porn
um what black is basically saying that
you know you have two porn weaknesses I
just have that bad porn on C6 but
ultimately those two Pawns in the middle
are just gonna be so much worse
long term these are targets the more
pieces that get exchanged the weaker
they will become sometimes white with
the spaces actually overextended right
that's kind of the principle of the
karakan white gain space but it comes
with downsides to long term so uh okay
interesting Break by Anish giri
attacking this white knight now I'm
assuming it comes back because there's
no other safe Square what else could uh
consider I don't think you should really
exchange off these pawns first because
now once the White Knight does retreat
to safety black is first to occupy the
open file also the key here is black has
a nice Outpost for his Knight in the
middle of the board this night is
I mean imperious now it just uh jumps in
thrifting night folks you kind of never
get rid of it on this Outpost and uh
yeah this looks very good for Gary if he
can achieve it but Prague needs to stay
calm maybe just Retreat his Knight
and the game goes on still very tense
thinking now for two minutes prank he
only needs a draw in this game to win
the match
and uh both of these two players are
sitting in Shaq 15 in San Francisco and
we're learning during this tournament
that San Francisco really is a place to
be if you are a chess player or if you
do love chess so many chess people are
in San Francisco and of course they're
taking their time to drop by Shack 15 to
look at the top chess players
John you're a celebrated just author
you've been an Insider in the game for
so many years what is your view on how
chess has changed over the years well I
started playing in the fall of 1972 and
things have have changed and quite
dramatically I'd say a couple things
that come immediately mind are there's a
lot more women playing there's a lot
more Juniors playing there's no smoking
in tournaments which I think is the most
welcome development and I think also
that there's a lot more Professionals in
the game I think there's just a lot more
Global interest in the game it used to
be that chess was pretty much you know
Europe United States and maybe a little
bit in South America and of course in
the Soviet Union and Eastern Europe but
today it's really really a worldwide
game you started playing around the
fish's basket match in the aftermath of
it like many of your colleagues how did
that match influence you well you know
it was a time when there was a lot fewer
things competing for people's interest
and so uh you know there was no cable TV
there was no internet uh so every
evening uh you know you would turn on to
the news and there'd be Walter Cronkite
our big newscaster and you know he'd be
talking about the Vietnam War to be
talking about you know domestic affairs
but first in Reykjavik he'd lead off in
what happened in the games and all the
newspapers uh covered the match
extensively so my friends and I we we
just got interested in it and I was very
fortunate that I lived near Seattle
Washington town called Tacoma and they
had a very active Club at the time and
so uh the local newspaper reported they
were having a tournament and I went to
it and somehow 50 years have passed
since then wow and do you feel that just
has been able to replicate the Glory
that surrounded it during that match I I
think that some of the things about that
match would be hard to replicate for one
I don't think we would like to see
another cold war between the United
States and Soviet Union but obviously
that got people's interest uh uh you
know heightened even more than it would
have it also helped that you know Fisher
and spassky were two really Unique
Individuals that uh you know if it had
been two other players that might not
have attracted that much attention but
but even you know I would say that uh
more recently during the pandemic you
know with the Queen's Gambit with uh all
these internet streamers with all these
brilliant internet uh online tournaments
uh I think it it's it's it's just as as
big in its own way but in a different
way
you've captioned a very formidable
United States team in over 25 team
events tell us about that and what that
experience has been like uh
well uh I got to be a relatively
reasonable player I got to be an I am
with a feeder rating around 2470 and a
couple Grand Master Norms but after
Captain the first Olympiad team I
quickly realized you know as Clint
Eastwood would say a man's got to know
his limitations and I definitely
realized you know to be associated with
all these great players it's been a real
privilege and a real honor and there
have been a lot of really memorable
events that you know been held in places
all around the world I would never have
probably visited otherwise so it's been
a real pleasure and what's been the most
important part of your job as a captain
to the team of the United States I think
just to let them be who they are I think
that you know I've been very fortunate
that I've never had any real problematic
players if you will we've always had
very good team spirit and the players
have always really enjoyed being around
each other so my job's been pretty easy
you know uh just you know go out there
and let them do their stuff and if they
do well they get the credit and if I
have problems with the team it's my
fault
you sound like a great Captain I'll have
to ask you with such strong players in
the team such established Grand Masters
does that also sometimes get a little
challenging you know uh if the Olympiad
was held more than once every two years
it would be a bit of a challenge because
chess is both an individual and a team
game but it's primarily an individual
game and so it is hard you know when you
have players that are playing against
each other all the time and it's their
livelihood and their profession and
everything they're dedicating their
lives to uh it is hard for them uh to
shift gears but every two years they
manage to do it
and you're also heading for the world
Team Championship uh in just about two
days but it's a very different team for
the United States this time how do you
assess your chances well you know this
is a a really a tournament that's really
hard to predict because it's being
played at a very unusual time control
it's uh 45 minutes aside with a 10
second increment so it's neither rapid
nor classical it's sort of going to be
like classical Chess at the beginning of
the games and it'll be like uh Blitz at
the end of the games uh so it's really
kind of hard to predict uh the
tournament was originally going to be in
March of this year but obviously events
made that impossible and so they
rescheduled the tournament uh in the
same venue to where it was going to be
before in Jerusalem uh but on relatively
late notice you know we got about I
think six weeks before the tournament
was going to be held the problem is with
professional players at the very top
they usually set their schedules out
about a year in advance so we're not
sending our quote a team if you will but
the U.S bench is very very deep this
year you know right now and uh so I
think we have a very competitive team
but there's a lot of other good teams
including the Indian team which again
you know doesn't have like all of its
very highest rated players but it has
plenty good enough players I assure you
and it's going to be house is going to
be leading the US team how do you feel
about that having him on top board well
you know I've known Han since he was 10
years old he uh joined the Mechanics
Institute chess club when he was a
beginner and in the first year that he
was playing at our club he went from
beginner to expert to 2000 rated which
is you know pretty impressive and I
realized at that time he was going to be
a very special player and he's certainly
shown that I mean he's you know he's
2700 feet eight so I think it's going to
be a great challenge for him leading the
team you know and uh I'm excited to see
how he does we wish you and the team all
the best thank you so much John thank
you very much for having me
John Donaldson he has a very cool
jumping team captain for the talented
team
USA
and another Talent is Young Prague 17
years old he only needs a draw in
game four hair against the niche Geary
we actually only had I think two moves
because Anish was thinking for as long
as Donald Donaldson was talking but the
bar has jumped up slightly for Prague
yeah and that's purely because Anish
needs to win so he's taking big risks
and I've got to commence Prague as well
for again just surprising us surprising
Anish with some really anti-positional
dress but there's always tactical
reasons behind it and we have to jump in
to show why Prague has just won a pawn
and I think he will emerge a pawn up in
this transition so we did leave it
around here we've just seen a trade of
dark squared Bishops which we weren't
actually supporting for white but now
after Paul takes Pawn which again we
weren't supporting because it looks like
White's Knight has to retreat and if it
does remember Black's Knight gets this
dream Outpost in the center but Prague
had the sneaky idea up his sleeve and
I'm not sure I would even have this on
my radar he his idea was despite the
night being attacked to swooping and
jump in with the White Queen creating a
skewer along this line but also a pin on
the B file meaning that white now cannot
oh does not need to worry about his
Knight being captured because Black's
Queen would drop off and uh just due to
this tension white would win a pawn
while it's attacking this guy and this
guy and no way to save it it's just
really sneaky it's kind of going against
all wisdom but making it work using
tactics and that meant that Anish giri
in this position moved his Knight
instead attacking the White Queen trying
to force it back and it did indeed
Retreat to defend its Pawn so for
example Pawn takes Pawn now white
recaptures a queen trade remember it
helps prag get closer to that draw white
is also won a pawn instead a niche
trying to create some tricks along the D
file trying to create a pin but prag
saying no I don't care I'm just going to
improve my Rook and I think he's big big
favorite now to secure at least a draw
maybe even win this game because Anisha
is running out of material
Pawn down
big threat to pawn takes Pawn what else
is there to do you might have to go into
an end game now
trading queens and uh maybe you can win
one Pawn back but uh even in this end
game white is the favorite because a
bishop is better than the knights and
also these two have great potential you
see any chance of anchor for a niche
no is my answer to that it's very direct
I'm afraid but uh I just think white has
a great position and even in even if you
were to recapture the pawn as as in the
position you've got highlighted there an
analysis board to me white looks like
they have a significant Advantage
actually there on account of uh the two
versus one poor majority on the left
side of the board and the activity of
the Rooks and here come the trades
Queen's gonna capture and uh well if the
Queens are forced off
Yeah we actually see the position that
we analyzed uh it has appeared on the
board and yeah I mean you can give this
Pawn up like you said you can go active
with the Rooks um you can maybe even go
now and uh for example if the Black
Knight takes this Pawn in the center you
just drop your Bishop back very safe and
this is a big weakness it's an isolated
phone white tonight doesn't look great
but it is about to re-centralize
everything's defended
it looks fine black is quite active at
least this is Gary's best hope but it
shouldn't be enough uh I think Prague
with his great end game technique should
be converting this one or at least
drawing this one and Anish Geary he is
our final hope to have tie breaks today
because uh game four ended with a draw
between between you and Christoph Duda
and Mom Daryl and that means do that
takes all three points in that match
winning in the rapid portion and winning
his second match in a row he will be on
top of the table together with Magnus
Carlsen
after day two young crest of Duda the
two top players the season number one
and number two on the tour standings
Magnus and young Kristoff
yeah I think we're seeing a two horse
race uh the others will have something
to say about it but they look so
impressive Carson and Duda and they only
face each other on the final day of the
tournament young Christoph dude and
Magnus Carlsen imagine if that match
decides the winner
the tournament
yeah one winner to take it all yeah and
uh meanwhile black has regained the pawn
so Gary re-establishing material balance
but he's also offering a rook exchange
and remember pieces are disappearing and
yeah they're just simplifying the
position towards that desired result for
Prague and seven minutes it's
easily enough for the young Indian it
should I mean I just can't see any world
in which uh Anish can trick him here
yeah the only one who can beat Prague
now is Prague himself by being careless
yeah I I agree with you there David I
mean the first question on the board is
should you trade off Rooks I would do it
especially if I'm in a draw situation I
wouldn't even hesitate just like take
took those Rooks off the board retreat
the bishop to a safe square and then
maybe even just try try and trade off
another pair of Rooks yeah I mean just
to show this on the board just to show
why we're kind of so skeptical about
Anish Gary's chances okay wow he doesn't
even go for the simple approach uh
pregnant under this is very very
determined uh to trade off pieces he's
forcing an exchange of one set of
knights now uh White's night at the top
of the board it's protected sufficiently
indirectly by White's Rook at the bottom
also by White's bishop and uh yeah it's
also a double attack Black's Rook on f8
and the Knight on F6
both eyed up by White Knight and I think
he's found a way yeah he's simplifying
as we were trying to uh trying to make
happen but he's found it in an even more
direct manner and the evaluation bar did
go down slightly but that's because he's
trying to force a draw prank and he's
odds on to achieve it
I even if I were in a win a must-win
situation I think I would if I if I saw
it yeah I didn't see it I didn't see it
to be honest but if I saw it I think I
would play that move because you know
the rook and Bishop worked better than
the Rooker Knight and you have to bear
in mind that white has that uh trump
card those pawns there on the left side
and all he has to do is start advancing
those pawns synchronize The Rook Bishop
push pawns yeah job done exactly and uh
it sounds simple but it is it should be
that simple
um this night move again forcing an
exchange because there's a double attack
if the knights are exchanged now Bishop
takes and uh yeah let's assume that this
uh Rook trade happens too
as you say this Duo should beat the
black viewer of rook and Knight
um there is potential of an awkward pin
slightly awkward pin but you can break
this pin in a few ways you can step
forward with the pawn and then later
move your Bishop out the way to defend
your Rook offer a trade in that manner
you could maybe even be a bit sneaky
because Black's back rank is vulnerable
you can move the white Rook across and
as you say Ivanka Rook takes Bishop
firstly this ends in Checkmate you
cannot go for this but uh rook and
Bishop they do work so well if black
gives his King some breathing space just
bring your Rook into the game
attack this lone Pawn Black's Rook is
totally stuck Black's Knight unable to
really hop around and guard both sides
of the board it's a short range piece
that's why we prefer the bishop in such
end games and yeah what's to be done if
if you want to be really cynical and
forced to draw just bring your Rook up
trade off the remaining Rooks and uh
we're gonna see something like this
happen in the game uh even a bishop
versus nice scenario the bishop is still
the favorite pawns on both sides of the
board
I think at least you get a draw here
and uh this is if you really want to
force the issue so the current position
is this one with one set of Rooks being
traded and
how is Gary ever going to win this I'm
even surprised the evaluation Bar says
equal
it looks like he's in full control
Prague and Big Time Advantage as well
now okay Gary does try to give some
space to his King but uh the simple
approach for now for preg bring the rook
in up
and across
in each Geary fighting for his life to
take this to uh Tire breaks young
Christopher he decided it before Ty
breaks winning game four against mom and
yarrow and winning the match
congratulations young crazy stuff thank
you too much wins in a row you will be
on top of the table after today together
with the Magnus are you in top four for
the tour finals
um yeah hopefully I am and difficult to
say after you know only two matches but
um so far I'm quite quite pleased with
my play and
um yeah hopefully you know it will be um
I mean I will play like this still
development
and of course playing from poem I know
it's very late for you probably like
three to three a.m in the morning right
now uh now it's uh midnight right now oh
okay so it's not too bad is for me it's
like normal timing
um I'm gonna say because I think you are
one of the players who stay up all night
playing chess and then you sleep in so
this actually Suits You
yes I I mean I
um I was also in Canada not that long
ago and I'm kind of now you know kind of
struggling and and so I'm actually like
going to bed very late and um it's no
issue whatsoever to
um I mean for me to play in this time
because I'm kind of set you know have
like a
I mean I mean kind of American time zone
right now so
it's totally fine as if I was in San
Francisco yeah
fantastic now uh playing against mom jar
of who won a fantastic match yesterday
um what are you the most happy about
with your play today and yesterday as
well
um
I'm happy that
um you know I I've been very sad with
black I don't think
um like I gave him a lot of chances
you know to put a lot of pressure
and also I mean you are always happy
with the games you want
um but it was like um I mean this
Catalan game was very crazy because
um
I mean I I thought I was basicallying by
force and Mrs queenify response
after after that I was very upset and
didn't you know fully trust my
calculation no more
so um yeah but I mean we were both alone
time and
um and I was attacking so that was a
that was a good thing and also I mean I
wasn't risking that much apparently but
um okay it was it was very sharp and uh
as usual you know I couldn't have won
um I mean winning position
um also I'm very lucky in a way because
um I wanted at one point I wanted to
make a winning combination
I'm in trading you know uh exchanging
everything and then you know some Pond
race and
um I I thought I you know I was doing by
force but um but but then I you know
realized I mean I thought that there is
no reason you know to calculate
um make anything sharp you can do it
like you know I was stupid so I could
have done it you know without any
calculations and so and my instinct just
saved me because
um
because I uh I wanted to you know
sacrifice my queen to to regain it and
in two moves but I didn't realize that
my night was pinned so that would have
been actually a losing blunder in one
move so
um that that was uh you know that that
was that was crazy but um
but I mean
of course I mean I was kind of surprised
that I
you know couldn't
um couldn't find trackmate because his
King seemed to I mean so vulnerable to
me but um I guess it was like efficient
I mean good enough actually
I mean I mean the way I
you know try to convert it so that was
of course crucial game and
um and as always there are you know a
lot of Adventures in my games but um
yeah I'm very happy of course to win it
without and I need to play telework
great match win and Three Points finally
young Crystal I want to ask you because
there are some huge geopolitical news
today with some missiles sitting Poland
on the border to Ukraine uh being at
home in Poland is this something that
has sort of worried you or uh taken some
attention from you today
um actually I didn't know about it to be
honest oh
um
I mean of course it's
um
you can never you know feel like a short
that nothing is like going to happen
because
um I mean Ukraine is next to Poland of
course so
um yeah it's always kind of tense and
very drastic but um
yeah actually actually
I mean Poland has you know a benefit of
being not in NATO so that's for sure a
good thing and right now I mean I
I don't know how I mean the situation
will be handled to be honest and um but
I mean it's difficult for me actually
you know to
to be wise on this topic because I feel
like absolutely no clue but um of course
I'm
um
I I want to stay once one more time that
I'm against any War
of course and we're happy to see you
perform so well on the board the young
Christoph best of luck tomorrow as well
and congrats on your second match win
today
yeah thank you very much thank you for
joining us
it does sound a little tired young
Christoph Duda it's past midnight now
for the young polish uh 24 year old who
will be on top of the table together
with Magnus Carlsen after day two
can take his first three points in the
tournament if he gets a draw in this
game we had a few moves is that getting
closer uh in one way yes so a set of
Pawns have been traded off we should
still be heading towards that draw but
in another way I do feel as if Prague
he's played a bit passively he took some
slightly negative decisions he could
have been more aggressive more ambitious
he's let the black Rook active which is
maybe one downside to what's happened
and also
the white Pawn on the edge of the board
the white apron it still takes a while
to advance and if we look at the other
side of the board Knights are good when
there's only one half to focus on only
one flank to focus on and that black
knight could potentially become a good
piece so um
yeah I'm not writing this one off yet
maybe I was too harsh on Gary's chances
earlier and what do you think Ivanka
still should be a draw right yeah but I
agree with you I'm a bit puzzled by some
of prague's decisions like for instance
this bishop move I mean it looks a bit
strange to put the bishop on the same
line as the rook and there we see a
check and the King moved to safety
because it's very easily handled you
know the king just steps forward and
what white wants to do is white wants to
just Advance this Pawn
but uh Black Spirit can easily slide
behind this Pawn at some point and
you're abandoning your king and all of
the pawns around the white king yeah so
suddenly there's some risk involved
um so it should still be a draw of
course White's Pawn is very dangerous
the white apron maybe at some point you
can push it forward
and hope to be ambitious but
black has a clear threat now how do you
defend the white f-born the Black Brook
is looking at it you could step it one
square forward but that comes with a
significant risk maybe we can show the
downside here if Prague gets careless
and it takes his eye off the ball for
one second just moves his Pawn forward
which is attacked very natural then
suddenly
I'm really worried for his life here the
black porn stepping forward and again if
you get carried away this has all the
makings of a mating net and now you
really regret abandoning your king
because the black Rook is going to slide
behind it and trap it rook and knight
checkmate this is called the hook mate
hook mate I came out yesterday actually
as well rook and Knight teaming up
trapping uh the opponent opposition
Monarch so um yeah suddenly you don't
want to leave dark squared weaknesses in
your camp and that would happen if you
push forward with your Pawn maybe it's
still fine but yeah these dark squares
for the Black Knight to jump into
very very scary suddenly and if you
can't push the spawn forward maybe you
just lose it that's what I would do I
would sacrifice that pawn and I would
just go well quality is better than
quantity push the a Pawn Yeah makes a
lot of sense pushing forward two squares
away from promotion and if this Pawn is
gobbled up I guess you move your Rook
out the way I'm not sure exactly where
but let's say a square like this one yep
uh the black moves behind and now you
step forward yep and I guess prague's
idea is just to move the bishop to the
long diagonal Queen the pawn yeah simple
chess yeah promoting the pawn on A8 so
it is a light Square covered by the
bishop you still have some work to do
for example if the Black Knight stops
you from doing that but as soon as the
Black Knight moves away to prevent you
from using the C6 Square you can start
going after black spawns as well so this
should secure safety Prague however does
play a very committal move he instead of
pushing this Pawn forward he pushes this
Pawn attacking the Black Knight and
still seriously worried for the white
king if the Black Knight for example
Parks itself on the edge of the board
and uh
still the idea of taking this pawn and
still some checkmating patterns for
example if the white king protects this
Pawn whoops check and a different
version of the hook mate maybe uh the
king is trapped and okay Gary is going
for the white king which has been
abandoned
wow okay suddenly I have a feeling
things might be turning will we head
towards playoffs because yes Prague now
is going for this ah black porn but look
at the bar exactly things are dropping
and the rook and Knight combines so well
against an opponent's king and uh all
Prague needs to do here oh sorry all a
niche needs to do here is make sure he
puts his Rook on a safe Square for
example you can plant it now behind
White's Pawn
suddenly yes you might win one Pawn back
but this one is not going anywhere
anytime soon you cannot go back and
defend it really because now the king
it's in Mortal Danger
and the black king is going to snake its
way and become a hunter and this is
going to be going to see another mate
actually if it yeah puts itself on the
G3 Square then The Rook will swing
across and uh Checkmate on F2 the
viewcovitch Checkmate so
yeah I mean all sorts of making patterns
and Prague is down around a minute now
at least lost all control it should
still be a draw with best player you
feel but the computer says plus one that
means already the margin for error is
Tiny and uh yeah the rook and Knight
combo we normally say it's inferior to
the rook and Bishop but not when the
rook and Bishop is so far away from each
other like this Black's piece is
perfectly placed look at the black king
compare it to the white king essentially
black is playing with an extra piece
White's King is just a just a poor
bystander here and uh okay desperately
trying to get his Bishop back covering
these squares that's a good start
stopping the black knight from entering
but uh yep still I promise you drop a
pawn and you're Pawn down and every time
you grab a pawn I was going to say this
move is very risky as well because it
allows the black king to step forward
yeah the black king is coming in
it's on the brink and now pawns are just
on one half of the board pawns are just
on the king side and knights are better
than Bishops when it's just on one side
of the board we've been talking about
how great Bishops are but uh now white
has lost his pride enjoy the apron and
Anish time to run in he started that run
he is a great end game technician as
well and uh prag also strong but can he
compete with the more experienced player
he's already taken some negative
decisions this is why we say don't play
for a draw play the most principled
noose just keep long-term advantages if
you scare your opponent with the thought
of losing you're more likely to get the
draw long term anyway now it's just
one-sided white is begging for a draw
black is the only one who can win
drama will we see Ty breaks will Anish
Geary win another game he's under
pressure now prognananda
to get the jewel or win in this game is
that is a win even possible for Prague
in this game
only if a niche burns his Bridges and
completely gambles but uh right now yeah
it's definitely white on the defensive
look how trapped White's King is on the
corner
um the one Saving Grace for white is
that he's ready to check from the side
with the white Rook White's Rook is
going to drop back and start checking
kicking the black king away
so I like this night Retreat from Gary
there was no inroads with that black
knight so now you're rerouting it yeah
and I like this caption from ob1 me when
it's moved to 150 David smiles and the
good night closes in 10 minutes that
will have Simon a little bit upset that
is very good
on the clock uh I do feel that the
Prague has stabilized the ship somewhat
you know the Rook has come down is it a
great defensive role I think the only
thing that's missing is for the bishop
to come and park itself next to the king
Mary can live there I don't care if it
looks as ugly as anything it's a good
defensive piece and uh it's very
difficult to see a way for a niche to
March forward
yeah it's
it's it will involve re-routing his
Knight kind of rotating it back to maybe
swapping the positions of the black king
and black knight Black's Knight wants to
sit on the F4 Square that's occupied by
the black king right now we talk about
Knights on F5 but that's because they're
near the enemy king and the F4 square is
Black's version so somehow it will take
and we'll take a few moves a few
Maneuvers but
I think that might be the best bet for
black but only she has all the time in
the world we might be seeing this game
pushed to move 100 even
uh okay wow white only has two moves to
keep the balance already it's getting
critical uh White's King should move
here according to stockfish otherwise
Black's Advantage goes over plus one
when it gets to plus one that means
already white is on the brink
20 seconds
and okay he finds the third best move
but now Black's Knight is coming in
and uh okay here we go stop fish again
confirms black has a very strong move
the evaluation is rising in Black's
favor Black Snake can come into the D3
Square just next to the black Rook
supported there and yeah it's from there
it will be headed headed towards that
white king black also has the past E
Pawn remember so once the Black Knight
moves that black people could start
motoring down the board
and uh suddenly White's Rook is cut off
Black's King is threatening to break
onto the third rank
it's critical it is critical and uh he
has to make a move Retreat the bishop
attack the Knight otherwise the black
king is going to come in
and how many seconds 12 seconds 10
seconds for pregnant and his Bishop goes
all the way to the B7 Square
looks very scary blacks King can March
in look at this it's a losing blunder
he's lost coordination his Bishop's too
far away now and okay Black's Pawn
advances maybe this is strong too I
thought maybe the Black Ink can come
into G3 black was threatening to trap
the white King on the back rank no need
it just says push the E Pawn I mean how
are you going to stop that porn from
advancing if you're trying to give a
check the king is going to come forward
at one second gosh now Black's porn
advances you can even just defend this
Knight a bishop for nitrade won't help
white Black's Pawn is going to be the
killer we're gonna see tie breaks 100
this is why you don't play passively for
a draw you don't just play for one
result
the white king comes across but Black's
King can come even further in onto the
third rank Prague knows he's losing his
body language shows it
um yeah Black's just playing with three
pieces white is playing with only two
white king is trapped threat huge threat
of Checkmate White NOW King is trapped
blacks Rook wants to come to the first
Rank and the King has to run away I mean
he has to put himself on the worst
possible scars yeah
yeah killer blue now that white king is
almost helpless
how can black continue pushing his Pawn
you can't right now because the pawn
protects Black's Knight
if you give a check Force whites King
onto the edge of the board that looks
like a logical First Step okay first he
tries to trap again that white king
the other question is can you get greedy
here can you just take white spawns
it looks very tempting that is also
tempting but I do feel that you maybe
should keep your eyes on the prize
keep your eyes on the white king and
also promoting your past pawn and he
gives a check and moves his Rook along
the third row yep he's taking a step
back he's broken the pin now white white
now has to find something before the
Black Knight moves
white spawns are dropping as well
yeah the Knight is just so good against
the bishop when it's just on one flank
white Bishop is just so I mean it can't
contribute it's so far away
and misplaced it Craig's shaking his
head
four seconds for Prague again is he
gonna come back from this because
remember what can what to do and now you
can go back to the third option which is
just to get greedy grab those pawns and
instead he just mobilizes his Knight
puts it on the perfect square yeah we
talked about that F4 square look at the
Black Knight it's ready to take some
pawns ready to give some tracks protects
its king
and remember Black's past E Pawn just
push it down the board white is
completely Frozen now White's pieces are
so passive look at Prague he's
devastated he's throwing this game away
he was in the driver's seat he had an
advantage but he pushed too hard for the
draw and the pawns are starting to drop
if you take this Knight now which has
just happened White's remaining Pawn
will also fall rook in Portland games
are sometimes Jurish but not when
there's a two-point advantage and
White's remaining Pawn is also dropping
shaking his head yeah five seconds
this helpless blacks Rook will just take
one step back
you don't even need to think about that
just grab the material and when two
pawns up yeah look at Prague he's gonna
have to recompose himself for the tie
breaks heartbreak for the younger young
Indian and this is experience this is
pure experience and a niche as
the battle-hardened warrior that he is
he's found a way he kept the tension he
kept the game going didn't allow any
four straws and eventually Prague beat
himself self-inflicted this defeat
and uh Anish he's got 10 seconds himself
he does drop back yeah White's remaining
Pawn is rounded up now it's dropping
yeah he doesn't even allow white any
Slither of a chance of a counter play
you know he could have made an
inaccuracy allowed the white king to
enter the defense Anish accurate until
the very end yep and uh White's Rook
trying its best to hold against two
pawns but no this won't last for very
long Black's King can just step out the
way and uh both the two pawns will start
advancing yeah and uh actually if you
have to give away one Pawn I would say
just give away the G Pawn you wanna come
in and protect your Santa born and
there's no need for anything like that
just uh move the king
yep and uh here we go okay Anish just
biding his time repeating the position
to gain a few seconds extra on the clock
I have read somewhere that e and G pawns
that we have right now they are a bit
tricky you've got to be careful how you
advance them when you advance them
Black's Rook is a bit stuck right now
but uh okay he's going the long way
around Anish giri he doesn't want to get
the black king stuck in front of his
pawns he's gonna kind of bring the king
from behind there we go and support
in this direction yeah he's going to
kick the white Rook away
yes this is
I think sufficient technique unless the
evaluation bar whoa I mean it still
looks completely winning uh what's
Happening Here is there a glitch in The
Matrix ah I think there is there is it
should still be winning
um the problem for white is that slowly
and surely black will use this rock
he'll reactivate his Rook to uh he'll
kick back the white king and guide the
pawns hand in hand further forward
um yeah there are some scenarios where
you could hold a draw here with some
checks like this right now but Black's
King if you continue checking forever
Black's King will start sneaking in
front of his e-pawn and it will use its
own Pawn as shelter
yeah Gary's technique has not been a
perfect since he got the winning
position but it's still sufficient
slow and steady wins the race doesn't it
you don't have to be perfect in this
situations you can be good enough
and The Rook goes all the way to the
edge now is the time to
mobilize The Rook yeah you give a check
and remember the g-pawn is just
irrelevant it is the e-pawn that you
want to preserve because that is the
pawn that you're going to escort to its
destination oh hang on a second I'm just
looking the bar has corrected itself
what is the defense here because if you
get greedy now and take this black porn
with the white king your king is too far
away black Central Pawn is going to
March forward we will see this in the
game maybe there was a draw there if
there was it was a miraculous one that I
don't think any human would find and uh
okay now the white king is pushed onto
the edge of the board and that will
spell the end the beginning of the end
at least for pregnant and blackstruck
just needs to move on the G file look at
the white king it's cut off and uh
blacksmith Pawn in the middle
it's just gonna March down the board we
will reach eventually something that we
call the Lucina position I recommend
Googling that uh if you're unfamiliar
with that endgame Motif it's maybe the
most common way to win a rook end game
when you're one point up the Lucena
position
and we will reach that eventually so
that will involve Black's Pawn coming
down to the second rank the blacking
might even be stuck in front of it just
Sheltering from some tracks but there is
a way eventually to promote the black
porn to win white Rook
and um yeah when White's King is cut off
on the edge of the board like this
there's no way to avoid it simply yeah
and many many ways to win I've just
brought up the table base which is the
in-game database where because there
aren't so many pieces on the board and
when this is situation less than five
this is five six pieces they've been
worked out by the computers here totally
winning
yeah and this is in fact a win in 25
moves oh 100 mating 25 yeah
yeah that's if uh Anish giri goes for
the quickest win uh but yeah he's found
the way the king comes first
he's gonna guide the pawn forward if the
what Rook checks from behind the black
king is going to hide in front of its
Pawn this is the key if it had checked
from the side the white Rook the black
pawn would have blocked anyway any
checks so this is the way you kind of
Dodge checks you have to use the king
and Pawn in tandem together two seconds
for Prague he needs to move he made that
move with one second but here we go
we're almost at the Lucina position
where eventually the black Rook will
build a bridge in order to get the black
king from out of the checks from out of
in front of its own Pawn now it's going
to step back but uh building a bridge
that's reducing a position the Black
Brook will eventually ride to the rescue
and block uh any checks from the white
Rook freeing the black porn to run and
uh Prague resigns wow what a game it's
been what a comeback by Anish Geary
losing the first two games but then
winning in two must win situations